the raiders have a big game monday night
coming up and if you want to get into
allegiant you need to be vaccinated the
team working to make sure that everyone
has their chance to get the shot sasha
loftus joining us now live just outside
of allegion stadium with more details
tonight sasha
denise monday is the first raiders home
game where those coveted vaccinations
will be required here at allegiant
stadium team leaders want to make sure
fans are ready with clear rules and
alternative screening options
fully vaccinated fans should upload
their status to the clear app for the
quickest way into monday's game but
alternate screening is also available
saturday sunday and monday in lot b at
allegiant if you are partially
vaccinated have a vaccine that was
administered in another country or if
you're bringing a young guest if you're
not vaccinated you can get your shot on
site at allegiant
now if you are not fully vaccinated you
have to wear a mask inside we do have
more details on those alternate
screening options dates and times for
you on our website eight newsnow dot com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now